[Music]
we know you love Harry Potter who
doesn't but now there is a new fantastic
beast movie coming out and there are so
many things you need to know stay tuned
to find out what happened to credence
love Harry Potter check out our friends
at the CVR channel they made an awesome
video called everything we know about
the fantastic beasts movie now let's
check out some facts about one of the
most anticipated movies of 2018 duels of
plenty there's no relationship quite
like the ones that we have with our
siblings it's quite love-hate
sometimes you love your sibling and
sometimes you can't wait for them to get
away from you in this new movie the
sibling relationships are definitely
something to pay attention to and the
trailer for the movie we see one sibling
relationship play out right in front of
us
Newt has an older brother named Theseus
scamander one thing you may not know
about Theseus is that he is a vetted
Aurore he is also considered a hero for
his work in the First World War
so these years is definitely a boss in
the preview it is unclear whether the
two brothers were fighting together or
against one another if they are fighting
against one another then you can only
imagine what kind of battle this is
going to be Theseus is a proven fighter
with a track record of tearing people
into shreds but Newt is really coming
into his own and contend for himself as
well on the other hand if they are
fighting together then this is
definitely a duo who we can't wait to
see together it's going to be downright
amazing new locations if you watch the
Harry Potter movies or read any of the
books then you know that the story took
place in England because of this viewers
of the first fantastic beasts movies may
have been a bit surprised to find out
the movie took place not only in England
but not even in Europe the first film
took place in NYC first trip to New York
yes but if you were just getting
comfortable with the NYC setting then
you better get ready for another swish
because this movie looks like it's going
to be taking place in Europe we aren't
exactly sure where the majority of the
movie will occur but in the preview you
can see that they are in France in the
clip newt takes his beasts through the
French Department of the regulations and
control magical creatures in this short
video it looks like his beasts are
causing quite a ruckus at the
apartments do you think that France will
be the location of this film or will
they spread it out around Europe it
could be interesting to watch them
travel through different cities it could
add a new element to the movie that we
haven't seen before in any Harry Potter
or fantastic beasts movie lettle is
strange
Oh young love isn't it a beautiful thing
at least until it goes south we all know
when it's like dealing with an ex it's
awkward and uncomfortable and depending
on how the relationship ended it could
be downright horrible remember the
estranged family well apparently they
have more of a connection to neut then
we may have thought metal estranged and
newt apparently had a very close
relationship while he was at Hogwarts in
the first movie we even saw that newt
kept a picture of her amongst all of his
things we don't know their full history
but it seems a little sticky we don't
know if they split up before or after
Newt left Hogwarts and something weird
must have happened between the two of
them for them to split and Newt still
kept a picture of her who does that he
must still be in love with her can you
imagine keeping a picture of your ex on
you how could you possibly get over
someone if you're still carrying out
pictures of your ex
newsflash nudes you can't anyway we are
super excited to find out more about
this relationship and figure out what
exactly happens between these two and
why she's back in the picture whatever
the reason is it can't be good
Jude Law close your eyes and think of a
superhot actor now open them who did you
think of well if the answer was Jude Law
than you are in luck he is going to be
in the new fantastic beasts movie he
will play Albus Dumbledore who we all
know will go on to be headmaster of
Hogwarts and this film Dumbledore will
ask Newt for his help it has to be you
and we will also get to see newts past
relationship with Dumbledore apparently
Dumbledore was one of the people who
argued against Newt being expelled from
Hogwarts years before the movie starts
if you look at the newest edition of the
textbook fantastic beasts and where to
find them you can see a Ford from Newt
it says that Dumbledore was more than a
teacher for him he also said that he
couldn't talk anymore about Dumbledore
without breaking the official magical
secret Act or betraying Dumbledore all
of that mystery just makes us want to
know more about Dumbledore and newts and
how they are connected their
relationship seemed
like it will definitely be a focal point
of the film it's always interesting to
see Harry Potter characters and their
lives before the Harry Potter movie
started Elder Wand power is always
important but in a magical world it's
even more crucial in the world of Harry
Potter and fantastic beasts there is
always a fight going on between good and
evil if you don't know much about how
power works in this world then let us
break it down there is one specific wand
that is better than all the others it
gives whoever has an extreme power in
the wrong hands it could be extremely
dangerous get it okay well in this movie
we see that Grindelwald has the Elder
Wand if you read the books and you know
that Grindelwald stole the wands from
the wand maker Grigorovich very early on
so it seems like most of the movie will
center around the fight against
Grindelwald the trouble is that now that
Grindelwald has the wand it will be a
lot harder for anyone to overcome him
which is sad for Newt and Dumbledore but
on the other hand it makes it much more
interesting for us to watch Newt and all
his beasts against a pretty much all
powerful being sign us up to watch that
please after hearing this are you more
interested in running to see this movie
timeline movies can go one or two routes
when they are a part of a series the
movies can either take place one after
the other or there can be time between
the films this can be as little as the
next day two years in between films when
the first fantastic beasts film
premiered fans wondered what the next
movie would be about and when it would
take place would it be the day after the
first movie ended or would there be a
substantial amount of time in between
well we have the answer and we are ready
to spill it the second movie will take
place right after the first one ended so
we don't have to worry about any gaps
between the movies or wonder what
happened after the first movie ended the
movie will pick up right after the first
one left off but we won't be staying in
New York there have been hints that the
movie will take place in London and
Paris are you going somewhere no we're
going somewhere if we are in England in
this movie then we will be getting to
take a look at Hogwarts it always seems
fair that the film would take us to
newts old stomping grounds right how
could the film be set partially in
England and not go to Hogwarts Creedence
it's always sad when one of your
favorite characters in a movie passes
away it's
you're missing someone that you actually
knew right it's easy to become attached
to characters in the two-hour time
period that we get to know them at the
end of the first fantastic beast film it
looks like Creedence who is played by
Ezra Miller had passed away this
happened while he was in his obscurus
form which is a dark force that appears
when a witcher wizardry presses their
powers while it may have looked like the
ends for credence that is actually not
the case which brings us to the point of
how he survived well the simple fact of
that matter is that we just don't know
we saw the same movie that you did and
in that first film it definitely looks
like all was lost for dear credence but
let's look at the facts most obscure
eels don't live past the age of 10 since
Creedence is obviously older than that
that may mean that he has become super
powerful and that may be how he managed
to cheat death we aren't sure how he
survived spots if the promo pictures and
videos are anything to go by then at
least we know that he did survive new
characters like we mentioned before it's
easy to get attached to characters in
films it's like for two hours or so they
become part of your family so when new
characters are introduced it's natural
to be a bit wary of them will they be
good or will they be bad can we trust
them are they really who they say they
are what's their backstory British huh
yes these are all questions that we ask
when new characters come on the screen
if you're going to see the new fantastic
beasts then you may want to go ahead and
get those questions ready because
they're going to be quite a few new
characters speed or the former The Daily
Show worker and actress Jessica Williams
she landed a role in the film asked one
of the new characters she'll be joined
by Wald Roth who will play a character
named
Spillman and Victoria Yeats who will
play a character named Bunty on top of
that
Derek Ritter will join the cast as
torque will traverse poppy Cory toosh
as rosier and Cornelis John will join as
Arnold Guzman recognize any of these
names if you think back you'll probably
notice that Travers and Rosie were the
last names of two Death Eaters in Harry
Potter any relation curses in a world
like that of Harry Potter and fantastic
beasts it only makes sense that there
are more than a few curses going around
we guess that curses don't necessarily
always have to be bad
you may be cursed to do something that
is perfectly fine like fall in love stay
single etc but in most cases like the
one that we are about to discuss curses
aren't the best things to have in this
new film there will be a new character
introduced named maledictis this
character will be played by Claudia Kim
this character will unfortunately have a
blood curse this curse will make her
transform into a beast the curse seems
to be different from being an animagus
as we know animagus is can turn into
animals by choice this person on the
other hand seems to be struck one way or
the other to further understand this
character we can split up her name the
word mal means wrongful or ill in Latin
and ictus means to speak in Latin so her
name means something along the lines of
speaking wrongfully taking her name and
her curse in two accounts it would seem
like this girl is not going to have the
easiest time in this film team
characters we know we keep talking about
the characters in the film but we only
do that because the characters are so
important to the movie they essentially
make the film especially if that film is
one in a series the only reason you
watch a series is to see how the
characters lives turn out why else would
you tune in for another film if you
didn't like the characters in the first
movie then there really is no reason to
watch the second it's all about
progression if you agree then you'll be
super happy with what we're about to
tell you in this new movie we will see
younger versions of some of our favorite
characters these characters include Newt
Scamander
level a strange Albus Dumbledore Gellert
Grindelwald and a new character named
Sebastian we know this because there was
a casting call put out calling for
younger versions of the actors and
actresses who play those roles so if you
love to watch the progression of
characters then this will be a real
treat it's like watching time move
backward we started getting to know them
as adults and now we get to see some of
what caused them to be like they are you
know Newt is not a great follower of
orders how could that not be interesting
and that's it for our video before you
go make sure you check out our friends
at CBR and their video on fantastic
beast smoothie whose video did you like
better come let us know and don't forget
to give them a big thumbs up if you love
anything comic book related see
next time
[Music]